good morning everyone please be seated
please now invite
reverend jim edie to say say prayers
over to you jim
thank you ed
wow well
that year certainly seems to have flown
by doesn't it
you probably recall
that last year we gathered for the agm
in the playhouse theater masked and
socially distanced
i reflected on the lockdowns we'd seen
go by
and the way many in our communities had
rallied
to support those in need
if i think back i think i had quite a
lot of pride
for the communities i'm involved in
all that they had done
and i'm sure you did
and the story of the good
samaritan
a year on
the places we call home the places we
serve
have moved on
to haven't they
many of the annual community events the
clubs the groups are up and running
again
and as we look to june plans for the
platinum jubilee are in full swing
and i'm sure many of you are involved
the scars
are present though
especially here in the streets of
stratford and across our country where
although they are busy again
some shop fronts tell their own story
once full of displays
they now stand empty
a year ago none of us expected a war to
be raging in mainland europe
and the worst cost of living crisis in a
decade to hit
and for me
that sense of community momentum to
provide support
also doesn't seem so obvious now
that's not to say it's not there
just uh last week i dropped in a local
project
that is still quietly distributing food
to those in need
a vital service at this time
but
continue to remember
that story of the good samaritan
as you go about
your business
a story that encourages us not to walk
past the excluded and neglected
and for me
if god so loved the world he gave his
only son words from john's gospel
that also includes the natural
environment that we so easily
neglect
so
whether inclusion exclusion
and neglect
in our communities comes
from wealth or lack of it
ethnicity
sexuality
disability or religion jesus tells us
through the parable of the good
samaritan
to hold out a hand to those knocked down
and help them up
just before i pray i'd like to say thank
you all for including me and listening
to me over the last year
and
on this role
but as we move on and move forward i
will pray the words of john newton as i
did last year
father help us to live this day to the
full
being true to you in every way
jesus help us to give ourselves away to
others being kind to everyone we meet
and spirits help us to love the lost
proclaiming christ in all we do
and always say
amen
thank you jim
uh please may i uh remind members that
this meeting is being uh broadcast live
and that members
um of the public are able to view the
proceedings so most importantly whilst
any secret balance is taking place aside
will be a slide will be
displayed on the website informing
members of of the public that the
meeting will resume shortly
so please remember that um this live
teams meeting cannot be adjourned so
anything we say during this time
will be heard by the public
so moving on to item one we have the
election of chairman of the council
um
so i would please like to uh propose
that councillor mark cargill takes the
role as chairman of the council and i'll
seek a second please we've got
councillor jennings
is that all in agreement
great and are there any other
nominations
[Music]
perfect
okay please now i invite councillor
cargill to take
the role of chairman thank you
well thank you very much indeed um
what a
privilege to serve this council and i do
appreciate that thank you very much
indeed
the first thing i am apparently have to
do is to
uh sign the declaration of acceptance of
office and i need to read this out
i mark cargill
having been elected to the office of
chairman of the council of district of
stratford uneven hereby declare that i
take upon that office upon myself and
will duly and faithfully fulfill the
juices of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability
i undertake to be guided by stratford on
avon district council's code of members
conduct in the performance of my duties
i think that is for you to sign as well
david thank you very much indeed
i would now like to invite
my wife catherine to come up
to be my consort for the following year
thank you
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
thank you very much
right um
i'd like to say a few words if i may
naturally i am looking forward to this
year
uh although i have absolutely no doubt
it'll be interesting
and also a challenge as catherine
is also mayor of ulster
now uh so that's their second term to
sell different chess i suppose you could
say it's
buy one get one free i don't know for
you
on the historical note um
in the 1980s i think it was that or 87
was it i can't remember when the rural
district councils were
subsumed into the
stratford-on-even district council
my father was actually chairman of
ulster rural district council as well so
i suppose i'm
following in his
his footsteps albeit a few years
along the way
as is customary i had the privilege to
support some
admiral organizations in the coming year
the first is dementia
now dementia is saying that touches many
of us over the years
is an umbrella term
for a range of debilitative
progressive conditions
that affect the brain each type of
dementia stops a person's brain from
working properly in specific areas
for example their ability to remember
think and speak
doctors use the word dementia to come to
describe common symptoms
such as memory loss confusion
as i mentioned speech and understanding
and they do get worse over time
i'm sure we all know people this
affected
my local organization the ulster cafe
has been helping those with dementia for
10 years now
uh and not only support and help them
with dementia
but also
the the carers upon there is a huge
burden of care
we've been working together as i
mentioned for some time to create a
permanent home for them as well and
we're still working on that but i hope
i hope that we can actually create
something special for for them and uh
the people with dementia
however i would also
like to engage with other organizations
uh throughout the district
and i would welcome an invitation to to
meet with them over the coming year
the second organization i wish to
support has been in
existence officially since 1824
but i have no doubt that people perform
the same courageous task many years
before
this is personal to me
and may at first glance be a curious
cause to support
due to our location that is as far from
the series as possible to get
it is of course the rnli
uh my direct connection is through my
time as an officer in the merchant navy
but also my father's family who are
fisher people in our growth in scotland
the r and l i rely solely on donations
to form their often dangerous work
and have touched the lives of many
people over the years having saved over
140 000 lives in their 200 year history
which is quite amazing
out of interest the first unsinkable
lifeboat was invented in 1785
and the principle still applies to rnli
lifeboats today
thank you
[Applause]
i would now like to
thank
the outgoing
chair
ed
thank you very much indeed
uh for his time this last year which has
been
an interesting one again because of
course we went from
uh effectively
the as you mentioned uh they think we
had the introduction
his first meeting was at the um
civic center
and of course socially distance now we
are able to
come together
as we can see today
um
the motion is that the council and it
sounds very
severe doesn't it the motion that the
council offers its sincere
congratulations and thanks to councillor
fitter for the exemplary manner in which
he carried out the duties of chairman in
the council in 21 22. it's far more
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
uh thank you mr chairman
as the councillors would have noticed i
kept my meetings as short as possible
mainly because i've always been pretty
shy when public speaking so 12 months
ago i was really horrified to learn that
my first meeting would be under the
lights on stage at the stratford play
house it's safe to say that my next
career move won't be in the theater
when i joined quinton parish council as
a 23 year old um so i'd like to express
my thanks to every single councillor
here because you all gave me as a new
councillor with little to non-experience
in my twenties working full-time still
attending college uh the opportunity to
represent this cat this council
and i'm truly grateful
so i tried to make my year as engaging
as possible so in november uh organized
a council tree planting session uh where
we planted 125 trees and then i had my
ball and bingo
my thanks to our council officers
um
thank you very much indeed
and well done in your year uh
yes i will be carrying on with the
instagram account
and uh
yes and looking forward to uh
to lots and lots of uh posts on that
particular social media thank
you right uh next is a slightly unusual
one in as much as we have uh give thanks
to our
uh vice
chairman
uh tony dixon who actually of course
sorry
oh i'm going to go through the election
of that first of all oh yeah i was going
to get to that ah of course i was right
no problem
okay election vice chairman of the
council
um
i would like to nominate jill foreman
council george foreman
and i'm looking for a seconder
thank you very much indeed kasabi are
there any other nominations for vice
chairman
in that case jill you're it
i jill foreman having been elected to
the office
upon avon hereby declare that i will
take the office upon myself and will
duly faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability i undertake to be guided by
stratford-on-avon district council's
code of conduct members conduct in the
performance of my duties of that office
[Applause]
thank you now we can go into
council dixon
um again this has been an unusual year
because uh
well tony obviously was chair
for a year and that was an awkward
period wasn't it
um
best forgotten i think is is a way to
say describe that
he also has now been a vice chairman
over the past year
and is now picking up some of the things
that he was going to do while he was
chair
so um i'd like you to come up and if you
want to say a few words i'll just say a
few words from where you are over your
or your year thank you very much indeed
yes i have now right
yes it was uh it decided to be an
unusual time to uh to take on the vice
chairmanship again um my third time but
that particular role but
obviously although some people were
thinking i was going to be sitting where
you are now mark i uh
advertised from the very start that i
was not going to do
a third year
in the in the chairman's role as such
but certainly it's been a very useful
time and very helpful time
uh then during my advice to both capsule
kettle and uh and to ed um i had
extremely busy this year but certainly
there was those occasions when his diary
just could not fit in two of
appointments at the same time so it was
nice to actually be involved to a
certain extent but at the same time i am
also pleased to be uh standing down as
well
obviously i i did end my year with a a
bit of a a fundraising effort
and i'm pleased to report that uh my
target for uh
1460 pounds to raise being 10 pounds per
mile for my walk from the globe theater
to stratford-upon-avon i'm within about
a hundred pounds now of that target
so it would be nice to actually hit that
target etc
but certainly i am very pleased that the
weather we have outside today did not
occur at any time in the last fortnight
my feet have recovered my muscles seem
to be recovering and i'm now looking
forward to a week's holiday
next week
so any any uh committees in the rest of
it i think there might be a committee
meeting next week
i'm going to be missing
thank you very much chairman it was a
good year and i'm pleased to hand it
over thank you very much indeed
and well done um the vote of thanks
again i'll see
calcutta
okay
the voter thanks to the retiring vice
chairman
is that the council offers its sincere
congratulations and thanks to council
dixon for the exemplary manner in which
he carried out the duties of vice
chairman of the council 2122 we must
come up with something better for that
we'll do that next year thank you very
much indeed
[Applause]
i'd like to now move into the meeting
proper
uh apologies for absence
german thank you apologies have been
received from councillors adam bromwich
eden
harris henshaw seraphin
kendall o'donnell parry pemberton and
richards thank you
thank you
item seven oh sorry six is the
disclosures of interest uh members are
any disclosures of interest
okay so we don't need one you can sit
easy it's okay
right um item seven then is a statement
of the leader of the council council
jefferson
thank you chair uh the latest statement
was on the desks for people to read
it's an extremely long and thorough
document
i think the main item in it is that
cabinet numbers have been reduced by one
so with that
i commend the leader statement
thank you council jefferson
okay item eight is political balance and
again i invite council jefferson as the
leader of the council
to introduce this item
thank you chair
once again the political balance which
is a routine calculation
i should have been circulated
with the meeting thank you
you should all have on your desks and
membership committees there are a couple
of amendments to the membership of
committees that i need to make you aware
of because that's going to be very
important for the next
part of the the meetings this morning
so in relation to the audit and
standards committee
councillor fielding will not be on the
audit and standards committee will be
replaced by councillor o'donnell on the
schedule that is in front of you but
councillor fielding will replace council
o'donnell as a substitute on the audit
and standards committee
in relation to the overview and scrutiny
committee councillor foreman
will not be on the audit overview and
scrutiny committee and there will be a
vacancy within the conservative
allocation at this point
on the planning committee
the vacancy that's shown on the schedule
for the conservative group will actually
be filled by councillor jill foreman so
we have a few amendments in relation to
the um
schedule that's on your desk thank you
thank you david
right
um as mentioned we will be now
um
pausing the meeting for a few moments to
allow our guests to go and uh have a
drink in the members room
oh counselor yeah okay um and then we
will be moving on to the appointment of
committees it's only just
it's
procedural so i don't think you'll be
interested in seeing that
exciting for some of us but not not all
so i'd like to pause the main note
sorry um
yeah we certainly will that is a real
shock um
thank you very much for informing
council
uh councillor uh
kettle that's a that's a real shock and
we'll we'll certainly do that at our
next meeting um a tribute to him thank
you very much indeed
okay um so i'm gonna pause the meeting
now if our guest would like to go into
the other room they'll be escorted
and you
and then we will move into the next part
of the meeting thank you
members thank you
shall we move on please
lunch beckons
i'm now going to
hand over thank you
thank you very much i'm now going to
hand over to the chief executive mr
buckland
to move through the
the audits and standards our first
committee thank you
thank you chairman as members will be
aware this part of the meeting needs to
appoint the chairman and vice chairman
of the audit and standards committee to
help us with that could i please ask
that the members of audit understand
this stand when i when i call your name
uh councillor crump
councillor of curtis
dixon
we have apologies from o'donnell fitter
foytec
foreman
wally hoggins
uh petaguela
and councillor rock
thank you
we have one apology for absence which is
councillor o'donnell
item three is the appointment of
chairman so do i have any nominations
for the chairman of the committee mr
warley hoggins
thank you is there a second of a council
defeater
dixon thank you are there any other
nominations councillor curtis
thank you it's your second for that
i like to second the nomination can i
bring counsellors to youtube microsoft i
know that they're a little bit flaky
this morning okay so we have two
nominations for the uh chairmanship of
the audit and standards committee in
which case there will be a secret
counsellor oh sorry uh point of order
please
uh if i may um
i don't think that the the lib dems
group
would question the appropriateness and
propriety of appointing his chair to an
oversight committee an employee of the
conservative party
[Music]
that that might be
your your view but legally that's quite
possible
it may be possible but i would
as a group we do question whether it's
appropriate and whether it in it
instills increased public confidence
in our communities and our decisions
thank you council curtis i have no
problem with the nominations that have
been made for the chairmanship we will
now move to a secret ballot you should
all have on your pay on your desks a pc
oh are they coming around
just bear with me councillors thank you
are the members of the committee clear
what that what that is expected
okay thank you
liz if we can just concentrate on the
ones in the auditing standards for now
for the chairmanship of the audit and
standards committee so it is the the
members that we have stand in
can i can i just check
of all the councillors you just write
your name please on on whether you're
voting for council of fitter or you're
voting for councillor rock on your piece
of paper which will then be collected
from you thank you
and i will just stress it only those
members of the ordinance standards
committee that can vote on this so liz
could you please click the
the votes in thank you
thank councillor together
thank you just bear with us one short
moment we'll now count the votes thank
you
okay i can confirm that the majority of
votes cast were cast in favor of
councillor fitter and therefore
councillor fitter is appointed as
chairman of the audience standards
committee that's where to hand over you
now for the appointment of the vice
chairman thank you
thank you very much
members of the audit standard committee
so now we will appoint a vice chairman
do i have any nominations for the vice
chairman of the committee i would like
to please propose councillor wally
hoggins as vice chairman
is there a secular
yes chairman i would second that
proposal are there any other nominations
no thank you
perfect so um i will note um that the
next scheduled meeting of the audit and
standards committee is on monday the
25th of july thank you
thank you the next item is the
employment committee
mr buckland
thank you chairman um same pack drill if
i could please ask the members of the
employment committee's stand councillors
alcock barker
cleave
poetic
foreman ian pratchley harvey jefferson
and pemberton is an apology for today
thank you
so
if we have everybody standing thank you
um i
have one apology in councillor pemberton
appointment chairman do i have any
nominations for the chairman of the
committee council barca um can i
nominate councillor tony jefferson
please thank you is there a second of
that nomination can i second that please
thank you council harvey are there any
further nominations
without any further nominations
therefore i can declare that uh council
jefferson will be the chairman of the
employment committee thank you
thank you members of the committee
um
i'm going to uh propose councillor
pemberton as vice chair of the committee
do i have a second to please councillor
barker
i can't i second councillor pemberton
thank you
are there any other nominations for vice
chair
so there are no other nominations i
declare uh councillor pemberton vice
chair of employment committee
thank you
uh next is uh overview and scrutiny
committee mr butland
okay thank you chairman could the
members of the overview and scrutiny
committee please stand which are
councillors cargill crump
curtis
fielding
fitter
inferentially
junid
mills
rolf
and wally hoggins
remember we have one vacancy on the uh
committee
so i do apologize for the mics we'll try
and get them sorted for this afternoon
um do i have any nominations for the
chairmanship of the committee
that's lafitte
please may i um propose councillor krump
as chairman of the committee thank you
is there a seconder
thank you councillor fielding
do i have any further nominations
councillor rolfe
uh yes i'd like to nominate
curtis
okay so as we have had sorry i
are there any further nominations
okay so we will be running a secret
ballot again all the members of the
overview and
committee will receive a purple piece of
paper if you could please write
councillor crump
or councillor juned on that piece of
paper and then we will count the votes
as we did before thank you if you could
please remain standing it will help us
significantly thank you
thanks
can you hear me yes um so i can confirm
that the majority of the votes cast or
cast in favor of councillor comp and
therefore councillor trump will be the
chairman of the overview and scrutiny
committee thank you
both over the council
thank you mr brookland
we now come to the appointment of the
vice chairman
of the committee for 22-23
i would like to
nominate councillor susan junid the role
the vice chairman of the committee
i'm looking for a secondary
councillor off
have we any other nominations for that
role
so all those in
i favor that's okay
thank you
thank you mr junior
at cancer junior will be vice chairman
of overview and security for 2223
and just like to end the meeting to note
that our next meeting will take place on
friday the 20th of may thank you
i would like to ask
the chief executive
to uh bring the next item which is the
planning committee
board
thank you chairman i was just checking
with the monetary officer because we
have a number of apologies for this
committee but we we are court
so could i please ask the members of the
planning committee to stand with
councillors crump
who are here uh curtis
dixon
um
jennings
mills
i think that's it for today because we
have apologies from councillors adam
eden hensha seraphin
kendall and richards
okay thank you
so i now ask
if there are any nominations for the
chairman of
the committee councillor uh
yeah i would like to nominate peter
richards for chair thank you is that is
there a seconder
second one
councilman thank you are there any
further nominations
okay so council of riches is elected as
chairman
in his absence and therefore i will
continue i apologize for the sound of my
voice um
we now have the appointment of vice
chairman so we have two uh appointments
to be making relations to the vice
chairman of this particular committee
council fleming's got his hand up
already mark yeah
i'd like to nominate danny kendall for
vice chair
thank you is your second for that
councilor mills
i'll do the two for one is there any
nominations for the second vice chairman
of the planning committee i can pose
bill fleming thank you councillor mills
is your seconder
thank you councillor krampe
are there any further nominations for
the two positions on the committee
okay in which case i'd like to confirm
that counselor kendall and councillor
fleming are elected as the vice chairman
of the committee
um bill i can pass over to you for the
the the niceties about the next meeting
thank you
yeah the next meeting in the planning
committee is on wednesday the 18th of
may thank you
thank you all
and correct me if i'm wrong but the last
one is regulatory
thank you chairman we do we do see keep
the the most complicated until last time
so the regulated committee if the
members of the regulatory committee
could please stand we have a councillor
curtis
dixon fitter
fielding
jenny fragili
mills
riley rock shenton and wally hoggins
this morning i'm sorry i'm fixated on
this afternoon
do i have any nominations for the
chairman of the recollection of the
council wally huggins
thank you is your second
councillor
thank you are there any further
nominations for the chairmanship of the
regulatory committee
okay in which case i'd like to announce
that uh councillor mills will be
chairman and i'll be looking to appoint
the vice chairman thank you thank you
do i have
nominations for vice chair
for
for the regulatory committee
thank you council
i would like to propose
cancer wally hoggins for vice chair
and i'd like to second that
thank you very much indeed
and
chairs of licensing now
check chairman could you see if there's
i'm ahead of myself
do we have any other nominations
thank you i can go ahead now thank you
chairs of licensing
do i have any nominations for chairs of
licensing got three chairs
chairs are licensing
and do do i
is there a seconder
yes chairman i'll second that to thank
you
thank you thank you very much indeed
so
do we have any other
do we have any proposals
thank you
got there we got there
um thank you very much indeed um
well that's the appointment of chairs
um just going to regulatory um our next
meeting will be on friday the 24th of
june mr chairman
thank you thank you very much indeed
members
okay that brings the um procedures
of uh locations to committees to an end
and thank you very much indeed your
forbearance uh i'm now going to close
the meeting but there will be a buffet
in room five which is around the corner
and so i will ask you all to be
available for the next meeting at one
o'clock thank you very much
you